we start with breaking news and
lincolnshire police have made an arrest
on suspicion of murder following the
death of nine-year-old lilia bellatoutia
in boston lilia died of a suspected stab
wound on thursday evening well earlier
today police released cctv images of the
man they wanted to speak to as part of
their investigation
well let's uh
have a look at those cctv pictures but
we'll speak now to fraser moored um
fraser this breaking news then that
police have made an arrest
on suspicion of murder
that's right the images were released
late this morning
and since then police say that they have
been following a number of leads it
appears that one of those leads at least
has led to an arrest i'm here just
waiting for chief superintendent martin
parker to step in and give the details
as uh in the form of a press conference
if i walk out the way now then
chief superintendent parker can step in
and we can get the latest situation
hello
follow following our appeal on the
release of the cctv
i can confirm that we have arrested a 22
year old man
on suspicion of murder
he is now in police custody
officers detained the man in boston
central park area around 2 45 pm today
the arrest follows a combination of
intelligence and information supplied by
several members of the public
i would like to thank everyone
for their assistance as we continue our
investigation
we are still encouraging anyone with
information to contact us
and you can do so via the major incident
portal of which the details are on our
website
once again
i would like to personally thank you
for the support you have shown from mems
of the public and from the media
your support is very much appreciated
i anticipate that there are several
questions that you would like to ask of
me
we are in a very sensitive stage of our
investigation
having just arrested a 22 year old male
please allow my officers the time and
space
to conduct their
inquiries and continue the investigation
thank you
so chief superintendent
martin parker not taking questions in
relation to that statement that he's
just given but the news is a 22 year old
man is arrested around quarter to three
in a park area in boston this afternoon
police unable to confirm at the moment
whether or not they are looking for
anyone else in connection with this
investigation at the moment whether
there are there are other people of
interest but they say that this arrest
has come as a as a result of information
coming from the public now they released
cctv images uh late this morning they
will put out four images which were
taken from cameras on a hotel and uh and
bar uh just about 100 meters or so from
where i'm standing and only about 30 or
40 meters away from the actual crime
scene itself four images were released
they've been put on all platforms the
media has assisted the police in putting
those images out for the public to be
able to respond and it seems that the
public have responded it will be a great
relief to many people in boston speaking
to people here today there were still
many concerned parents saying that they
were they were too worried about letting
their children out particularly after
yesterday there were there were
reassurances from the police saying that
two people had been arrested and saying
that this was an isolated incident those
two people we found out this morning had
been released without charge
and the cctv images of this main person
of interest were released by police as
their investigations continue the chief
superintendent there saying that this is
an investigation which is still ongoing
which is still fast moving despite this
arrest there are investigations are
continuing and what else is noticeable
in terms of public reassurance following
the release of those two people who were
arrested yesterday is that there is very
much a strong police presence here in
the centre of boston today lots of
community support officers police
officers have been patrolling the area
many of them conducting inquiries but
many of them here as a sign of
reassurance to all the communities here
in boston of course lily are part of the
lithuanian community and they have come
out in their in their numbers to to lay
these tributes here there's been an ever
growing number of tributes to the little
girl who loved to dance a nine-year-old
who was stabbed in the street uh
only a few meters away from where we're
standing now has caused a real
outpouring of grief from people here in
the community and that grief was tinged
with concern as well that the person
that was responsible had not been
apprehended there's no indication
whether the person who's been arrested
today the 22 year old man is the man
responsible for what happened here on
thursday evening at around 20 past six
but police say that this is clearly a
significant step forward in their
investigation so the latest news from
here in boston uh that in connection
with the uh the the death of a
nine-year-old girl here on thursday
evening a 22 year old man has been
arrested by police this afternoon in
central boston and is currently helping
them with their inquiries